la réforme des rythmes scolaires
pourrait avoir une conséquence plus
inattendue l'organisation des
associations locales qui proposeent des
activités le mercredi ou le samedi matin
c'est le cas du club de football DL
encour le samedi les créneaux sont pris
par les jeunes pouss et les U1 par
exemple jouent leur match le matin en
tout une centaine d'enfants concernés
mais la chance ici est de disposer de
plusieurs terrains on a déjà commencé à
penser un peu comment s'organiser alors
c'est vrai qu'on a quand même la chance
à en cours d'avoir trois terrains
saétiques donc ça ça quand même permet
quand même de faire certaines choses
donc je pense que en cas de en cas de
problème de terrain on essaiera de de
répartir sur les deux terrains
différents on passera les Sami
d'après-midi je pense que ce qui sera
enfin je pense que la décision sera
prise au niveau district de football
puisque là au niveau département il y
aura sûrement des orgisations de de
prise en commun l'école de foot
deslancour accueille environ 400 jeunes
pour l'heure pas de contact pris
directement avec le district
départemental mais des échanges
informels et les clubs sportifs
attendent eux aussi d'en savoir plus sur
la date d'application de la réforme et
sur le choix de la demi-journée
supplémentaire travaillée le mercredi ou
le samedi cela peut changer bien des
choses